Voy a hablar
de una idea muy pequeña:
el corrimiento del punto de partida.
Y como la idea puede explicarse en un minuto,
antes les daré tres ejemplos
para hacer tiempo.
La primera historia
es sobre Charles Darwin, uno de mis héroes.
Él estuvo aquí, como saben, en 1835.
Quizá crean que perseguía pinzones,
pero no fue así.
En realidad recogía peces.
Y describió a uno de ellos
como muy "común".
Era el mero.
Se lo pescó mucho hasta
la década de 1880.
Ahora el pez está en la Lista Roja de la UICN.
Pero hemos oído
esta historia muchas veces,
sobre Galápagos y otros lugares,
así que eso no tiene nada de especial.
Pero el caso es que aún venimos a las Galápagos.
Aún pensamos que son prístinas.
Los folletos todavía dicen
que siguen intactas.
¿Entonces qué pasa aquí?
La segunda historia, también ilustra otro concepto:
el desplazamiento de la cintura.
(Risas)
Porque estuve allí en 1971
estudiando una laguna en África Occidental.
Estaba allí porque crecí en Europa
y luego quería trabajar en África.
Pensé que podría integrarme.
Me quemé mucho con el sol
y estaba convencido de que yo no era de allí.
Esta es mi primera exposición al sol.
La laguna
estaba rodeada de palmeras,
y, como pueden ver, de unos manglares.
Había tilapias
de unos 20 centímetros,
la tilapia de barba negra.
Y la pesca de esta tilapia
era muy abundante y pasaba por un buen momento,
así que se ganaba más de la media
en Ghana.
Cuando fui allí 27 años después
la cantidad de peces había disminuido a la mitad.
Maduraban a los 5 centímetros.
Experimentaron una presión genética.
Aún había peces.
En cierto modo, aún eran felices.
Y los peces todavía estaban felices de estar allí.
O sea, nada a cambiado,
pero todo ha cambiado.
Mi tercera historia
es que fui cómplice
en la introducción de la pesca de arrastre
en el sudeste asiático.
En la década de 1970 -bueno, empezó en la de 1960-
Europa realizó muchos proyectos de desarrollo.
El desarrollo pesquero
supuso imponer a los países
que ya tenían 100 000 pescadores,
imponerles la pesca industrial.
Y este bote, bastante feo,
se llamó El Mutiara 4.
Yo salí a pescar en él,
y realizamos estudios
en el sur del Mar de China Meridional
y, sobre todo, en el Mar de Java.
Lo que allí capturamos
fue algo inenarrable.
Capturamos, ahora lo sé,
el fondo del mar.
El 90% de lo que capturamos
eran esponjas,
otros animales que están en el fondo.
Y la mayoría de los peces
son manchas diminutas sobre unos restos,
restos que son peces de arrecife de coral.
En resumen, el fondo del mar llegó a la cubierta
y luego fue arrojado.
Estas imágenes son extraordinarias
porque la transición es muy rápida.
En un año, uno hace un estudio
y luego empieza la pesca comercial.
El fondo pasa de ser
un fondo sólido de coral blando, en este caso,
a ser un lodazal.
Esta es una tortuga muerta.
No las comieron. Las descartaron porque estaban muertas.
Una vez capturamos una viva.
Todavía no estaba ahogada.
Entonces querían matarla porque era un buen alimento.
Esta montaña de restos
es lo que recogen los pescadores
cada vez que van
a una zona en la que nunca han pescado.
Pero no queda documentado.
Transformamos el mundo
pero no lo recordamos.
Ajustamos el punto de partida,
al nuevo nivel,
sin recordar lo que estaba allí.
Si generalizamos esto
ocurre algo así.
En el eje Y tenemos cosas buenas:
biodiversidad, cantidad de orcas,
el verdor del país, el suministro de agua.
Y eso cambia con el tiempo.
Cambia
porque la gente hace las cosas con naturalidad.
Cada generación
usará las imágenes
recibidas al comienzo de su vida consciente
como lo normal
y lo extrapolará hacia adelante.
La diferencia es que
perciben la pérdida
pero no perciben la pérdida que ocurrió antes.
Uno puede analizar la sucesión de cambios.
Y al final mantener
unos miserables restos.
Y eso, en gran medida, es lo queremos hacer ahora.
Queremos mantener cosas que ya no están,
o que no son lo que fueron.
Pero uno debería pensar
que este problema afecta a las personas
cuando las sociedades depredadoras
matan animales
sin saber lo que han hecho
hasta unas generaciones después.
Porque, obviamente,
un animal que es muy abundante,
antes de extinguirse,
es poco frecuente.
Uno no pierde animales abundantes.
Uno pierde animales poco frecuentes.
Aún si esto no se percibe
como una gran pérdida.
Con el tiempo,
nos concentramos en los animales grandes,
y en un mar sinónimo de grandes peces.
Se vuelven poco frecuentes porque los pescamos.
Con el tiempo quedan pocos peces
pero pensamos que ese es el punto de partida.
Y la pregunta es:
¿por qué aceptamos esto?
Bueno, porque no sabemos que era diferente.
De hecho, mucha gente, científicos,
cuestionarán que era muy diferente.
Y lo harán
porque la evidencia
presentada en un modo anterior
no es de la forma
que ellos esperarían que tenga la evidencia.
Por ejemplo,
la anécdota que algunos presentan,
como que capitán tal y tal
observó muchos peces en esta zona
no puede usarse
o, por lo general no la usan los científicos de la pesca,
porque no es "científica".
Así, tenemos una situación
en la que la gente no conoce el pasado,
aunque vivamos en sociedades instruidas,
porque no confían
en las fuentes del pasado.
De allí el papel enorme
que puede cumplir una zona marina protegida.
Porque con las zonas marinas protegidas,
realmente recreamos el pasado.
Recreamos el pasado que la gente no puede concebir
porque el punto de partida se ha corrido
y es sumamente bajo.
Eso es para las personas
que pueden ver una zona marina protegida
y pueden beneficiarse
de la visión que proporciona,
lo cual les permite borrar su punto de partida.
¿Y qué pasa con las personas que no pueden hacerlo
porque no tienen acceso,
como la gente del Medio Oeste, por ejemplo?
Creo que allí
las artes y el cine
quizá pueden llenar el vacío.
La simulación.
Esta es una simulación de la Bahía de Chesapeake.
Hace mucho tiempo había ballenas grises en la bahía de Chesapeake;
hace 500 años.
Y habrán notado que los matices y las tonalidades
son como de "Avatar".
(Risas)
Y si piensan en "Avatar",
si piensan por qué la gente se conmovió con la película
-sin hablar de la historia de Pocahontas-
¿por qué conmoverse con las imágenes?
Porque evoca algo
que, en cierto sentido, se ha perdido.
Por eso mi recomendación,
la única que daré,
es a Cameron, hacer "Avatar II" bajo el agua.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)